from the post millennial Joe Biden
cashed $200,000 check from brother James
business deal house investigators reveal
now the check says loan repayment which
is funny because how do you track the
record of when was a loan given was it
even a loan so there's a lot to break
down before we even read any of this
I'll just say very simply what this
shows is this check you know it could be
completely on the level maybe maybe just
just gave his brother a loan right
that's all it was okay here here brother
here's money for you it shows that Joe
is directly involved in the finances and
the business dealings that his brother's
engaged in this is his brother going
James going to Joe and saying I need a
loan for insert project and Joe saying
you got it which makes Joe the finance
here of these things that is the best
case scenario for Joe that all he did is
helped finance his brother's business
dealings or something a component of
what his brother's involved in you can
make the argument oh maybe it's personal
no I I I don't accept that because when
Donald Trump was doing tried to get the
G7 at Trump Dural arguing that he would
do it at Cost with no profit everyone on
the left and even me we we all said no
it's still a direct payment which
benefits Trump's companies this right
here is still a direct payment
benefiting his brother who is engaged in
these Shady business dealings it I think
at at the bare minimum shows his
brothers involved now the worst case
scenario of course is Joe's getting paid
off now now when you look at the Hard
Evidence and you can see 10% for the big
guy and all that I think it is clear now
you connect the dots this is
circumstantial evidence that when they
said 10% for the big guy when they were
talking about paying Joe Biden a loan
repayment could this be what Hunter was
talking about when he said his dad takes
half his salary could this be the fee
paid to Joe a loan for his name now what
actually is pointed out in the article
is that the reason so what happens is
americore gives James Biden alone James
then that day writes a $200,000 check to
Joe which looks like money laundering
yeah and it says it says payment on the
check which is um there's no way to know
as yet if Biden had actually given his
brother a loan so comr James comr wants
to know whether Biden has the documents
to prove that he had lent $200,000 to
his brother um whether he had similar
arrangements with other family members
and Marjorie Taylor green said exactly
what you said Carter that it's a classic
example of money laundering I mean yeah
I didn't want to overstep with that but
it looks exactly like that well if if
and and it's so it's so overt I mean
come on look it might not be but when
def like fa okay Omer cor was failing
and apparently out of business but still
had money in the coffers writes a check
for $200,000 to James who then instantly
that day writes $200,000 for Biden it
looks like americore is giving Biden
money yes it sure does look like that
and also the other thing too is if it's
not a loan repayment we have the
situation where Donald Trump is being
tried in New York by Alvin Bragg on what
is it like 37 counts of falsification of
business records so could this perhaps
be if if Biden didn't give his brother
loan then this is the falsification of a
business record did it go down a good
point yeah did it go down in his taxes
as a loan repayment how has this been
Quantified what are his booking
bookkeeping records looking like if
Trump is being brought up on these
charges um it's a civil suit against
Trump but basically I was I saw this I
started laughing I'm like oh so
everything they accused Trump of doing
they did right and they said well that
was that was a criminal that's a
criminal case the Alvin brag one is
Criminal oh I mean in in the civil case
in New York where they're arguing he
falsified business records yeah that
Alvin brag one that's that's isn't that
criminal no it's a civil suit it's I
don't know if it's the Leticia James in
New York that's a civil suit the Alin BR
of
bus what I'm saying is the suit against
Trump right now by laa James is a
lawsuit to determine whether Trump FAL
ified business records right and Alvin
Bragg has a similar case yeah but the
that that one was about Stormy Daniels
wasn't it yeah it was about the money
that Trump paid to Michael Cohen and
then Cohen paid money to Stormy Daniels
so this is very much like that one this
is very much like that lock him up lock
him up Joe's got to go they make the
rules not us and we you know we are
humbler humble followers of those laws
so man you know it really breaks my
heart to say this but we're going to
have to arrest Joe Biden and you know
he's going to have to go to jail well I
would love to see the Department of
Justice actually do that let's get the
FBI involved they should really start
digging in correct the only way isn't
that what's up now like raid his house
okay go for it do do you want to see Joe
Biden get arrested right now for this
cuz I can tell no no I can tell you
exactly how you can see it if you want
to see Joe Biden there is one way that
you can see him right now get arrested
for this it's called mid Journey you
just type in the prompts Joe Biden gets
arrested that's the only way you're ever
going to see citizens arrest in Georgia
or something like that nope just AI
generated images and then you can
fantasize and pretend like the world is
actually safe and there's accountability
but uh you know other than that have fun
that's like how my mom used to always
watch the westwing she was just obsessed
with she was like this is how I just
fantasize
reality oh that's so sad the reality the
reality of the internal workings of the
White House is probably oh right now
with Biden is probably so dark like they
what did they find they found crack
right or I was just thinking about that
what cocaine in
the in the white house right somewhere
in the I grew up so I grew up with the
Biden like Dynasty ruling over my state
for years and years and it's like well
known it's just like kind of public
knowledge that they're like super
corrupt the Biden run everything you
can't get past anything and their kids
are a mess too like was that the was
that the story on Bo Biden as well was
he considered boid was like the Beloved
you know but also he had a lot of
backdoor stuff going on between like
northern Delaware and Southern Delaware
and like paying off politicians for
Bridges and Road repairs and stuff like
that so there was a lot of like even
corruption back then I wouldn't say he
was a man of character um based on what
I know of him but the Biden's like I saw
what he did to the bidens did to my
state it's almost unlivable now in some
parts and yeah and I'm watching him do
it to America as soon as he was elected
presid and I said oh boy not good so no
this is interesting uh Michael super
chated saying loan repayment in the memo
was was uh not written by the same
person oh you think well I don't know
about that I mean the Super Chat did but
if uh I've got the picture right here so
if you uh if you take a look the
argument is that the writing for 200,000
and0 you know 100 uh and loan repayment
are
different I don't know what do you guys
think I think they look they look the
same to me but I certainly am no
handwriting EXP
expert I was blasting a stink bug I
don't like those guys but you don't like
them they're funny I know they just
smell bad they and they clap I know
they're great there's one hanging out in
my kitchen at home right now actually
but um yeah it doesn't look the same to
me it looks looks pretty different the
lowercase T's kind of look different do
they where's there a lowercase tea at
the very end and lone repayment and
then it looks like there's a capital T
in
thousand
yeah I don't know I mean I'm not a
handwriting expert but they you know
they they said that they're more angles
what did they say uh the writing has
more of an
angle I can see that actually the
repayment is written with a slight angle
to the right meaning at the very least
if they wrote 200,000 they shifted the
check as they wrote again giving a right
word angle angle to their
handwriting but but anyway if that were
true and I'm sure they are handwriting
experts who can either just bunk or
debunk it then um the the implication
being made here and I I don't know if
that has any Merit the implication is
that uh when Joe received the check he
wrote loan repayment on it himself right
or someone else did someone just wanted
to make sure that they literally dotted
their eyes and C their this this is not
a payment it's a repayment it's a loan
repayment maybe maybe it just said loan
payment you know the I I don't think
we're going to get anything from this no
I you know uh yeah they're going to say
look it's a brother lent his money his
brother some money that's all it is I
think that a lot of this stuff I mean I
think that what keeps happening is that
the House GOP has the goods on Joe Biden
and it's just not going to go anywhere
no matter how much um no matter even
though they have the majority they don't
really have any power at this point in
Congress um the Democrats have a lot of
power to you know they went along with
Matt Gates you know in the uh outting of
McCarthy uh whether you like that or not
you know that they did that um that was
a the Dem rats had all the power there
over the majority of the GOP which was
my main concern about the outing of
McCarthy was like it just sort of gives
up the GOP power what what what was
there well even they didn't have that
much anyway yeah I mean that's sort of
the thing we don't wield our political
power ever we're well known for being
like the losers because they can't raise
money if they're like if they're winning
you know what I'm saying that's the
thing when you say we it's like no no no
no like the The neocon shill
Establishment Republicans
are not us or not you they're they're
the reason they don't wield their they
wield their power against you right so
when everyone's like why won't the
Republicans do anything no no no you
don't understand they're using all of
their might and power to crush you the
person who voted for them well they're
still just doing that unip party thing
and that's why it's the moderates now
who are like in a position to make deals
with Democrats GH it's pretty gross it's
pretty gross but that's the concern is
that we're not going to get anything out
of this no matter how many smoking guns
they bring no matter how many
yeah like direct how much direct
evidence of bribery there is we're not
going to see um accountability from the
Biden family plus the B like Biden's
going to be out I don't think any of us
think that he's actually going to be
president for the next term you know
like they do you think they're going to
run somebody else I don't know I mean I
just don't see how he could
possibly serve another four years he can
barely I saw a video of him the other
day and I didn't even it it was very
weird it looked like a from Disney World
kind of well he does the old man
dementia Shuffle very slow and like the
it's the shuffle it's the like I'm
afraid to fall down thing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at timcast.net